hey everybody and welcome to a truly
impressive wild ride with stevo i'll
tell you
this world is full of people who have a
dream to work
in the film industry making movies very
few of them accomplish that dream and
far fewer still have the industry
approach them because they are that
talented and this week's
guest is that talented
he's an icon of hip-hop
and film and tv the guy's on fire
so let's get into it ladies and
gentlemen
thereza yeah dude in the building
hell yeah i would like you to meet my
co-host scott randolph
what's going down what up scott what you
doing with that microphone
what do you mean i should put my hand
down huh yeah
um well hey man thank you so much what
an honor
uh i feel like we met once before at uh
some place on the sunset strip and i
came up to you and i said hey man
i just want to acknowledge that incident
when uh we were at rock the bells and
and i got naked on stage
wait hold on hey stephen wait no stop
yeah
if you want to tell that story i gotta
tell them okay please do
no so of course everybody knows
jackass they know the surveys the movies
right
and i even had a chance to
had a few drinks with johnny in
knoxville the one some other movie
i went to the premier and some friends
and all that and
but i never really met no other guys
from the team
rock the bells uh 2000 what five or six
every year that was
2006. you're there
and you are already friends with method
man yeah correct uh-huh okay
so i guess you had a conversation with
me i kind of sat down with you there was
in the hotel
place whatever lobby was all talking
[ __ ] and you asked meth
you would like to do a special tribute
thing for odb
and that was like sound cool to me talk
to the abbey and i was like yo
i was i said yeah yo sound cool you're a
funny [ __ ] you do [ __ ]
you and you you you specifically said i
want to do something that i
never did before and i was like okay
that's
[ __ ] okay that might be some [ __ ] i
don't know what it's going to be
but i was looking forward to what it
could it would be
and so look we didn't tell we we kind of
gave some of the rule members i kind of
like yo before we do the odb show my man
stevo won't come out
and do it yeah yeah everybody was like
cool it's all cool
but they might know what you was gonna
do now
you know there's a lot of words we could
use to describe you right you could say
bananas
off the chain bonkers
zany right some could say
crazy outlandish you know what i mean
inspirational
bold we could keep going right and i
think we had all these words
but before the night ended there was one
word that i know that you wasn't and i'm
i'mma get to that
right but so anyway so now we get on
stage
and you know you know we're about to
throw the song going shimmy shimmy y'all
which is the odb youtuber
like hold up wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait my man stevo's gonna
come out here
and he's gonna do something to represent
odp
if stevo goes in front of the whole
crowd about ten thousand [ __ ]
takes it and he did he did it so fast he
couldn't stop just be clear
right he gets butt ass
naked on the stage and then do some back
flip bam and everybody's like oh [ __ ]
but it was actually i flipped my my
wiener and my balls back and forth and
then i caught it in a mangina
and holding the mangina position i did a
backflip
okay i missed
and i mean
you know what that was funny that was
crazy
wrong's in you
yeah the problem was that odb's mom was
there
yeah she was on the screen and what
happened exactly his mom was there
and plus look the woo was seriously
testosterone aggressive guys you know
that right
it's so so the thing that
the thing that i learned that day about
you right
and i know this i don't know it's gonna
be offensive or not okay
the thing i learned i said you know what
he could be all those words i named
earlier
but he ain't stupid
and what i mean by that because yo when
we thought it was all
done and you know a few of us laughed
and some people had their mouth ah
and and and oh you know moms was kind of
like what the [ __ ] was that
all of a sudden stevo was brought back
to the stage
by rayquan yeah i was still on the stage
and everyone was having a great time
shimmy yeah
and i think rayquan stopped the music
and he grabbed me by the neck
and he says yo i don't appreciate what
you just did
and and he says uh i'm i'm ready to
knock you out in front of all these
people i'm i'm ready to go to jail
go to jail you're like uh you know
you're gonna apologize right now
and you never saw me apologize faster
but that's the point i'm saying and when
rayquan said it right he said it
and he had you you know like that he's
somebody to go to jail then he kissed
his hand like
like yo you know when the black dude
kissed his hand like
that means like [ __ ] made to die
right now
right so you know what though now i
didn't
i know that like i said i know your work
i'm like man this dude does mad [ __ ]
is he gonna take this punch because that
was good
but if i said if you take this punch
he's stupid
right it ain't funny it ain't crazy it
ain't bonkers and that would be
foolishness right now you're foolish and
he was like
nah you apologize you know what i mean
you know i actually saw the footage of
the event
recently as because it was on camera and
and what what i said i said
hey i said i'm sorry very quickly and i
said i didn't mean any disrespect
i love odb and and that was
meant to to be respectful something like
that you know and and
yeah yeah no it ended up it ended up
good and the party went on and said
yeah then
for you guys i had like a team of
security to come and tell me hey
it is not safe for you to stay here
you're going to come with us and ushered
us out of there
do you remember what you did after
you're like dude did i like did you go
to the bar after
and you were like i don't know i was so
drunk at the time i i
this was previous to me getting sober
and i think when i met you i think i had
become sober and i came up to you and i
said hey i want to acknowledge that that
incident you know and
i just remember you being so so warm and
and friendly to me you said hey man it
wasn't anything
and that meant a lot man it meant a lot
to me well look i said i'm a fan of your
work and
look just i know you that your way of
expressing art
is your way you know what i mean and as
artists we all find different ways to do
it and
you did it you did it your way people
were still copying your way other people
have picked up the trend and they
finding ways you know i just finished
watching uh
um tyler the creator has this new album
out right
pretty cool album too he actually
sampled the song from the gravediggers
uh one of one of my tracks on the album
which is pretty interesting as well but
you remember that when his career
started in his videos he was doing crazy
things
but i think jackass is the inspiration
to culture of that you know and even
after that we got things that came off
in
ridiculous and warnings and all that but
you guys pioneered something
you know i mean i mean the wasabi
wasabi yeah it's like so many different
things and
it was just like yo you know it's it's
your art
and so when you see when i see you later
on he's like hold on bro
look my art hopefully is is appreciated
uh non-offensive uh but
but thought-provoking but inspirational
in a way it could inspire
whatever emotion it inspires whether
it's comedy whether it's anger
whether it's appreciation that's what
art is for you know what i mean
and so as an artist or artist you know
and i was like yo cool
i know you i know you wasn't up there
trying to disrespect us if
look now to be honest with you if i knew
you was gonna
take your dick
yeah i knew what i was going to do and i
i think if i didn't tell you
i remember i told meth before it before
i told him i was going to do that and he
at first he was cool
he said yeah man that's great and then
he came up to me again
before you guys went on stage he said
hey man if you do that
it's like uh someone's someone's gonna
knock you out
and i and and i was i was all drunk and
i said dude
let him knock me out man otb would love
that
[Laughter]
i mean who knows man maybe he might have
uh could you sober up
i did man up that no i mean up now and
we'll like yeah for sure
that moment
it was just a different time it was it
was a crazy time
and uh you know we we were talking to
meth on this show
and i remember uh you know it's just it
just it's very healing for me to be able
to talk to you guys man
and uh i do have a a a pretty cool
history with meth and i also have a rich
history of being
butt ass naked and feeling good when i
look good
and if you thought that i was a master
at manscaping before
let me tell you what i did last month i
invited hundreds of guys to show up with
pubic hair and shavers and after using
well over a hundred shavers that day
i can tell you definitively that
manscaped makes
by far the best men's grooming products
on the market and their lawnmower 4.0
is the biggest pleasure of all to use
man it is great and i want you to try it
because summer's here and it's time for
you to look good
so go to manscaped.com
stevo and that's going to get you 20 off
your order
plus free shipping i'm telling you
too many guys out there are not grooming
and if you're one of them it's time to
go
to manscaped.com
stevo to get the best men's grooming
products on the market
at 20 off plus free shipping
so do it now and let's get
back to meth you know going back to when
we were we had him on wild boys when
he and i got together did different fun
little stuff like one time he
he rolled a blunt and and he threw it
across his hotel room
and i caught it in my mouth but i caught
it backwards with
the cherry on my lips and i didn't care
i wasn't going to drop that blunt man uh
this was my shot
so i caught it and but it burned my lip
and then i said to meth i said yo dude
do i
do i look like i have herpes and we're
just laughing
i got i never even put that video out
but uh it's just it's just cool man
it's healing and and i appreciate
everything you said
you know i do take the art like pretty
seriously
man and and i i really really uh
connected with what you said about being
non-offensive you know because
as reckless as self-destructive
you know as [ __ ] crazy as jackass has
always been it's never been
mean-spirited man it's been like in a
weird way
it's been actually pretty wholesome you
know like we're
we do hard [ __ ] to ourselves and to each
other but we have
profound respect for for everybody else
you know and we're right
we're just not we're not mean spirited
and and we're we're here to
to uplift people and i think that we
have that in common man
we definitely do you know like i said
you know
watching some of y'all work even if you
just get the trailer of your movie
sometimes
remember that when jackass who trailer
came out and i just it just made me
laugh made me smile like these
[ __ ] were crazy
but the idea that if they could send a
tingle up a man's spine and he could get
a smile out of it
you know what i mean that's what that's
the joy of it you know what i mean so
for me if i drop a track and my crack
makes you want to move and it
tinkles up in your spine you're like yo
that's my [ __ ] we're doing we're doing
our job yo because we're building up
that territory
we're building up that dopamine in a
healthy way inside people's bodies man
now let me let me drop a bomb on you
dude we got another
trailer we got we got a whole new
jackass movie
jackass four and the trailers dropping
this month
and the morning is coming out in october
and what else is crazy too you mentioned
tyler the creator and how
a lot of his stuff was inspired by
jackass
well the production company that made
jackass made a tv show
with tyler and his crew called loiter
squad
and one of the guys from loiter squad is
a full
full-fledged new jackass cast member
this kid jasper dolphin
oh wow that's great yeah and we got
tyler
in the movie tyler the creator um
it's pretty crazy man because we're old
you know we're we're
we're properly like some of us are past
50.
i just turned 47. it doesn't make any
congratulations
man it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
for us to still be doing this
and what's crazy to me really blows my
mind is that at this
age which i never thought i would live
to i am
thriving man and and it's crazy like
you're even
just a little bit older than i am and
dude both of us
like it feels like we have not even
peaked yet
and we've got this we've got this legacy
man that we've built we've got this like
crazy
career and it just we keep building on
it you know getting higher and higher
and uh you know i want to ask you
something
going back to the beginning of wu-tang
because
you you put it all together you were the
the producer the
the the architect that you built it
and there's something from a business
perspective you did the first two
wu-tang albums
and then it just turned into a bunch of
solo albums you got odb's album rayquan
method band like all these solo albums
but the deal with wu-tang was structured
that those solo albums could happen on
any label whatsoever right and isn't
that kind of rare
that was revolutionary at that time um
and
and i think look it was
it was logical for us right and for me
as
a businessman knowing that
if you try to make everything come out
of the same faucet what happens if that
forces get clogged up
nothing's going to come out you know
what i mean so i had to make sure there
was multiple outlets
for for the product and for the energy
one because it's a big family
right the way the industry works it
would have been one album
a year probably but if you go and look
at 1995 i think
it was four albums in one year and all
four
ended up being platinum albums you know
what i mean
and it not only helped hip hop grow as a
whole
it helped the individual wu-tang members
grow it helped business grow it inspired
multiple people because look at the giza
album he was inspiring all the kids in
college
you know what i mean and having a
skateboard crowd into routine
odb basically was the you know to me
he was the dirty south of hip-hop like
before dirty south it was the old dirty
bastard and
and he actually he was the one that
actually helped us
kind of get into the southern hip-hop
world because he was so
unique and so attractive in his his way
method man has a decal album which we
got a grammy for
and ended up bringing women and children
and then rayquan and ghostface had only
built for cuban links
which was all the gangsters right so
every
field it was covered and and and we
wanted to
you know me as a strategist at that time
i had i was studying the book called the
art of war
by sun tzu and another book that's not
as popular
called the 36 stratagems and
i just knew that i had to utilize those
ideas into my business tactics in order
this you know to spread
the wu-tang vibe faster stronger
you know i mean have multiple companies
pushing the same energy
you know and it worked yeah man yeah
that's crazy i
i i was listening and you produce every
album you produce all those albums i
just think yeah
everybody's celebrating and having a
good time and you're just locked in the
basement
just locked up thinking i was locked in
the basement stevo for like
three years i didn't even know i was
rich
no seriously i didn't realize it until
like
almost three and a half years later
when it was just like like like like i
had money
i could blow money like you know what i
mean it's just like
yo you know our name sitting on hills
i didn't know it then of course my
character bobby digital
is born and i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
written
you know penthouse sweets and [ __ ] and
having a whole bunch of homies drink 40
ounces
and just live living that life that's
that's what led to that bobby digital
character which i will honestly say
i lost myself a little bit there you
know you were
you were saying like how right now
you're living the soul but life i'm also
living a sober life
i'm not drink but that's it you know not
even weed or nothing you know i mean i
kind of
put all that away um but i was i was i
was lost in a little tunnel
you know it wasn't publicly known but
it's just like i wasn't
i just let myself get loose and got
infatuated by
the party the drugs the sex the women
and all that
and and it it almost took me away from
where
who i could be you know i mean but i had
a chance to pause i got a good wife
uh and and and i got a chance to pull i
paused earlier though mind you
like you know i didn't only stay in that
chamber for a little while
but i i saw it and i was like oh [ __ ]
this is not what i was supposed to be
so that's why you got a new album
it's uh rakeem versus bobby digital
oh oh no y'all got oh the new album was
bobby digital versus darissa
oh god sure okay yeah which is uh you
know me basically
still lyrically thinking of what would
bobby digital be saying lyrically
what would the wrister be saying
lyrically right and both being two
personalities of hip-hop
and it's not i'm not let me just be
clear to you
and your brother and all the people that
check out the podcast i'm not
schizophrenia
okay all right i'm an artist
and i'm and i just find different ways
to express myself whether i'm in front
of the camera
behind the camera uh vomiting on the mic
in a way that's spiritually uplifting
or or rhyming on the mic in a way that's
going to eat another mc's [ __ ]
head off you know these are all this
artistic personalities that i've
compartmentalized in myself be honest
with you
and i'm able to just dab into them and
this particular project is called
bobby digital versus the original where
you get those two energies bouncing off
each other
i like it man so i'm just like checking
out and i said you know down in the
basement stinking because
like every different thing i saw which
which uh
referenced that period of your life like
there was a reference in each source to
like my underarms were stinking like i
just like i went
because you literally just didn't leave
the basement and uh
and dad loved that too man just that
that uh that workaholism man i think
like
you gotta hustle man you know go ahead
you might
i i was listening to something before uh
i got here and i was talking about you
took a lot of walks and you and you
thought a lot and you did all these
things
there's a certain it was really kind of
specific about that like you spent a lot
of time with yourself
and uh how much of that and it actually
like
taking a lot of walks and thinking about
religion and spirituality was the right
yeah and and then after that came
like this new way of doing contracts it
came this kind of like i'm going to put
these people together i'm going to do
this
how much of that like is was meditation
because then after you figured that out
now you're in
now you're in the uh producing and
you're not leaving the basement for like
you know three
that's like a vision that you had that
you couldn't stop until it was finished
how much of that was like meditation
kind of like a spiritual aspect of it
just to kind of reinvent the whole
way everything's done if that makes
sense it could have made a lot more
sense scott if i'm honest but don't
worry everybody because rizza is going
to handle this like a champ his
answer is epic but first let me tell you
about these
crazy cans of water which are showing up
everywhere
that look like tall boys of beer
it's called liquid death and why am i so
passionate about it well
as part of my bid to lose weight and get
healthier
i've been drinking a lot more water and
it turns out that's super good for you
but why is it called liquid death it
doesn't just
murder your thirst these infinitely
recyclable
tall boy cans are bringing death to the
plastic industry
that's right we're saving the world over
here folks
and i don't know if you're really
drinking enough water but i'm darn well
drinking way more lately and i'm feeling
better
so are you gonna get on the liquid death
train
because i think you should and if you go
to liquiddeth.como
you'll get a free set of koozies with
your first order of
any case they got the still mountain
spring water they got the sparkling
and i'm telling you this is a lifestyle
that i'm fully behind
so are you gonna go to liquiddeth.coma
right now to get that free set of
koozies with your
first order of any case of mountain
spring water or sparkling
i think you should i think you should do
it right now
but first let's have reza save scott
from his terrible question
i mean all of it was meditation brothers
you know i would say meditation is
better than medication
oh yeah you know what kind of meditation
do you do
well walking is my favorite form of
meditation
all right you know there was a great
indian monk named bodhidharma
who uh his you know his common name is
damo
who walked according to the story
of the legend he walked from india to
china
you know i mean when he got there
before he got there was only a couple of
hundred temples in china
that dealt with buddhism uh but after he
got there
and spread his message thousands of
temples sprung up
and the culture itself evolved and then
those same temples
my a priest some migrated to japan
and we called it zen so bodhi dhamma is
the father of
zen and zen means that anybody could get
the enlightenment
immediately you could get it from
looking at a stone you could get it from
taking a walk
you could get it from sitting in the
lotus position you could get it from
drinking alcohol
you could get it from sex right because
it's
in a total awareness of yourself and
everything else
most people are not even aware of
themselves right
they give a simple thing there's a great
documentary on uh
that's on netflix right now that i
advise people to watch is called the
human
uh the world within i was always using
this
these some of these ideas when i would
talk to people i would almost
tell somebody listen man you got you
know
60 70 000 you know
miles of blood vessels in your body
okay so if you take that along with the
respiratory system you'll get about a
hundred thousand
miles of blood vessels in your own body
that means you could wrap yourself
around the earth
about four times in your own body
and yet every time
every minute right the blood then
traveled all that distance
you're traveling faster than any
aircraft we made
any it's happening inside you
but you're not aware of it right not
aware
of the the nuclear reactor in you
right just to have the sperm in the in
the egg
colliding right and the sperm only has
one molecule of air in it
but that one molecule causes a
combustion and
mixed with the organic blood and from
these two cells
now you have trillions and trillions of
cells imagine taking two dollars
right and they and pitting it on
something and it turns into
i love it man i love it now anyway that
i i i'm with this the point i'm saying
is that
that contemplation ourselves that
contemplation on where you want to be
right ahead of time right if you could
keep the willpower
and the dedication and consistency and
persistency towards it
you can get there yeah you know yeah
that's what i was trying to say is like
most people don't spend time with
themselves enough to realize like what's
really going on
and i think that's different with you
and like why all these things happen was
because you spent a lot of time with
yourself and you're like
[ __ ] it i got a goal you know there's a
quote saying like hey look i'm driving
the bus you guys just get on
don't ask me where i'm going but i'll
get you there
yeah kind of like yeah that was that was
that's called the wu-tang brothers
yeah yo rizza i
i got a streak going 557
straight days averaging 41 minutes of
meditation
every day totaling 381
hours since december of 2019.
and it changed my life man met a mantra
based meditation
like like people do that they're
disciplined with it
and [ __ ] changes man your [ __ ] kind of
comes together
so i feel so worried about meditation
man i feel real strongly about it
and i want to know too because he's
saying oh how much does spirituality
affect me
i want to know how much does kung fu
kung fu is
everything right like the the wu tank is
kung fu the movies and
like i i want to know about kung fu and
i also want to know with your love for
kung fu
do you like mixed martial arts like are
you a guy who watches
the ufc fights of course i love mixed
martial arts
uh that's one of my favorite things to
be hanging out with my sleep fool
and we sit there and we watch the fights
he also i mean of course mma he don't
care mma k1
you know what i mean now they got the
bear
knuckles yeah
bfc or something yeah yeah yo
look because you know body's emotion is
always stimulating whether it's a
gymnast
a track runner swimmer body's in
emotions something beautiful
about man conquering the nature of
of an element or the nature of each
other you know something beautiful about
that and we always are attracted to that
kung fu is a great part of my life you
know i mean whether it's physical or
spiritual
mental or emotional so so that's enough
that's a big equation right there's
stevo the emotional part of ourselves
how do you
deal with that type of kung fu that
helped me a lot
understanding that even the emotion
right i looked at the word
and i was like emotion okay something is
moving
wow well i can't see it but something is
moving so how do i move it faster or
slow it down
or control the direction of it you know
what i mean so i started thinking about
that
and i learned that music can do it
and so this is why you listen to method
man he's like an inspector that one of
the lyrics is
wu-tang be attacking your emotions hit
you from every angle and form a circle
that was part of our energy was to you
know you're listening to a song like
tears
right and yet uh
it's a hip-hop song or song like cream
shop i say cream is a
was a love song right and here we are
turn the love song to a crime song
right you listen to a song like gladys
knights
can it be so simple and whereas he sung
about
memories in the sky and all this ghost
is talking about
uh i started off on the island a.k.a
shaolin
gunshots and [ __ ] so you're pitting you
sort of jumps of energy and emotions
you know name and then we still don't
forget to say
uh method man we're coming with
m-e-t-h-o-d man
which is to keep you up and bouncing but
it's still banging wu-tang star gets
your brain
j-u-m-p jump like it's still it's it's
all this
is these emotions knowing that
uh and understanding that uh it's a kung
fu
and i would advise you know people who
meditate to play with
to play with the movement of your
emotion one thing i'll do i'll give you
a quick
exercise if you're going to get into
this you may laugh at this or not but
i'll put on a song so gut-wrenching
right this is the song that stevie
wonder made blaming on the sun and
when i play this song it [ __ ] gets me
almost ready to cut my wrist
because it's that's he's it's he just
goes where's my heart where's my love
and he's lost he can't find it he's
blaming on the sun he blame it on the
trees because i blamed him on the day
that ended much too soon a day never
ends differently
it's that's the day but he blamed it as
if he didn't have enough time in that
day
right and then after i get down like
that
there's a song by this artist called
sizzler
a reggae artist called silent as a rock
i'll play that afterwards
right and he goes in you can't stop me
now
even if they put a roblox they sing cops
whatever they do
you can't stop me you know what i mean
and i pick those two
juts you know i may and my emotions go
from there to there
and then after i finish that little
point of of of of my energy
um it helps my day i may start off with
spa meditation music
right and end up with a with a uh with a
like i said with a with a drake song a
talent creator song a baby song
or just a rhythm beat and that's another
good form of
training your emotions and moving your
emotions so that now when the emotion
does hit you
based on somebody else's wave if it's
just a wave
when that wave hits you because somebody
else came angry or somebody was sad or
your kid hurt his arm or whatever you
now understand the movement
and you could deal with it calmly you
know what you're describing right now
especially with the taking a love song
and making it a crime song
that feels to me like maybe the
inspiration
for why when you come out on tour again
starting real soon
you're performing with an orchestra you
got wu-tang
and what's the orchestra right now we're
gonna use the colorado
well each city would be the orchestra of
that city so this would be the colorado
symphony
i mean that's that's epic i mean that's
epic dude
i don't know i know metallica did some
[ __ ] with an
orchestra which is kind of cool but i
like that that
that that's cool man that's fun i mean
you know it's just
it's expanding our music you know i mean
it's like like you said earlier you said
that we you know we continue to build
our brands and we continue to still be
here and
continue to thrive right it's because we
are artists
and art is a wave form and we know how
to adapt our art so here i am i'm on a
wild ride with you but we're sitting
still
yeah so
like and we've been talking about music
the whole time
but like with with the movies uh
you started out like you didn't you had
you had the one guy come to you
uh about hey i want you to make uh
was the movie was called ghost and and
this guy came together oh yeah jim john
moose yeah
he he wanted you to to to compose music
for the movie
you didn't really have the idea to make
him work on movies
he came to you and then but you had a
relationship with quincy jones
and you said hey let me let me see
you've got a mentor
in quincy jones and a guy comes to you
about working on a movie
like it just came together yeah and then
after that you got quentin tarantino
just bring comes to you about like like
you're not even doing [ __ ] it's coming
to you
right and and these are your mentors
your mentors are quincy jones and
quentin tarantino
that's badass that's respect you know
and i i thank those gentlemen for you
know
for not just i mean not only mentoring
me because they
you know those are men who are gracious
with their wisdom
you know i mean and it inspired me to be
gracious with my wisdom
you know there's a buddy of mines he's
about to direct his second movie
and it's because one day he was at my
house
and he asked me you know
how do i get into the movie business oh
well
i was mentored by quentin tarantino
right he was like wow cuz you
could you mentor me and i gave him some
wisdom
and he ended up doing his first movie
and now he's on the second movie
and the point is you know each one teach
one
you know of course it's a blessing to
talk to a great guy like quincy
jones you know uh isaac hayes also spent
about three years with him
of course joe james john woo you know
these are all great men
and you know still sharp and still
you know mean and the things that
they've taught me
you know first i have to be patient and
be receptive to it
and then the beauty of it was there
something they they was also
learning something for me right so no
egos is there so it was cool to
to you know to you know to learn about
the vibe that i was bringing to the
world at the time because remember the
woo vibe was
was new to the world you know what i
mean in the in the package we put it in
and so it was cool to pick up on that
wisdom and so each one teach one
you know yeah i think what we say is we
keep what we have by giving it away
that's it i like that yeah i like that
that's a good one man so
and now i mean it's it's pretty
incredible how on fire you are
at this time and with the showtime
series and the hulu series
i came and i guess like you know who did
it oj did it he had uh
there was the people versus o.j simpson
with the actors
recreating the whole story and it was
scripted and then they had the five-part
espn series
which was the actual documentary with no
acting
and they both at the same time had this
like rebirth of the oj story
good you you pulled yourself out of that
that was good what is it
but but now the word i'm not going to
hurt nobody
the real documentary series both at the
same time it brings about this
incredible
like heyday of the wu-tang clan like
this this
like pinnacle of
[ __ ] popularity and then now the
hulu series which is the one with the
actors right
is coming out with season two yeah
i mean that's insane and is that
something that they're at like as
a a film producer and a director like
are you
behind the scenes making all that happen
yeah what happened to me
right was i i think i was gonna share
this
this piece of information so i'll try to
pass raise it and i'll be
careful i'll share it but there did come
a point
that even though i was having success
i saw that the woo vibe was dwindling
right to me it was dwindling out of
hip-hop and swimming out of culture
and i saw other people telling the story
about hip-hop
and and they was kind of brushing over a
little bit
you know i mean there was a couple of
documentaries that came out and i was
like yeah wait a minute
they didn't they didn't you know they
may have gave two minutes to woo
in seven eight minutes to to other dudes
that learned from rule
you know i mean he's like yo you can't
leave out jimmy hendrix
when you want to talk about the guitar
you know what i mean so
so i felt a little like it was being
left out and i said well
we're also inactive out of sight out of
mind
and so i just constantly thought about
it and at the end i was fortunate that
uh brian grazer from imagine
uh he had put me on a tv show um for
game related
and during that process of that show we
became more familiar with each other and
he
read my book the dollar rule uh
and he also he told me later that he met
odb and he loved odb
right but odb was already past by the
time my book came out but anyway
he read the book and he optioned the
rights to that book
and then we talked about developing it
to something we didn't know what
and then when the idea when the when the
revelation came to me that way
the war was being dwindled out of
culture a little bit because of our
inactivity
we gotta and nobody can tell our story
like us i said well let me now take my
position and start telling the story
uh through the through this do a new
outlet which is through docu-series
and through scripted series you know i
mean
that's not an easy thing to do of course
like you gotta i mean you you know
you're talking about somebody gonna go
spend a hundred million dollars
on your idea now you know i mean but
the thing about wu-tang that i think
made it work
for for imagining hulu is that wu-tang
is an american saga
but then that within that wu-tang
universe you got the whole community
you know i mean it's like and through
our relations right whether it's
it's not it's not just the relations of
the wu-chang clan with each other but
the relation of the wu chang clan with
the world so method man as you see if
you ever watch the series
he's in long island and
and he's he you know he's he's an
athlete but he's not a basketball player
you know what i mean he's playing um
what's the what's the the the uh
huh lacrosse he's playing lacrosse
yeah all right no service like nothing
man played lacrosse
that's yeah right that's that's
something that's not
considered black urban but that's part
of america
right uh wizard goes down to a farm
in north carolina and and by me going
out to that farm
i saw it further than my projects oh
my um my mother working 40 italians on
staten island
that's a whole nother relationship right
there you know i mean the police
are friends with us but yet dangerous to
us
that's the whole so all these different
uh
tentacles of the rule makes it an
american
story you can't find this story in no
other part of the world nor reality it
takes america to produce
something like wu-chang clan um which is
a melding of cultures from asia
india black white
spanish um um um
all that energy is all melded into us
you know i mean
and and they they they saw the potential
of that
and we i had a great partner named alex
c as a as a writer
and we sat there and we wrote it you
know we wrote the first three episodes
ourselves sat there and we voted and we
wrote it just to share this with you and
i hope this inspired
one of your listeners we voted without
money
we just wrote it we agreed to write it
and we wrote it so
the one thing that most people will
overlook when it comes to art and
creativity and business
is that you have to create it
in order to have it to make it have a
so-called apparent
value some people want to wait to get a
check
and then do it right even wu-tang clan
itself
that first album it's just guys coming
to my house making music
okay it wasn't nobody paid you nobody
paid you to be there
you came there and you created and so
picasso he painted it after
the painting is finished the value was
put on it but
it's not no value on it until you finish
it
you know i mean and so we took the
initiative to
to write the first three uh and by the
time we got the
you know the green light we was well
prepared
and we just built from there and here we
are in season two
with some exciting on season two we also
uh
sat down and wrote the first pilot
episode first launch episode
meet the same team uh and uh
i'm really proud of this season i think
i think
i think we're going to tell the story
of an artistic band like wu-tang
in a way that so far
hasn't been done in the music genre i
think i don't think
i mean you know there's some great ones
out there but i think we
do a little cool swag that
only wu could do it that way you know
what i mean that's cool there that
so so we got season two coming out on
hulu
we got uh bobby digital versus the rizza
that's just coming out everywhere
everywhere music is sold in streams yeah
kung fu theater
comfort theater yeah that's out now so
my single is called saturday afternoon
kung fu theater
you'll go ahead and stream that if you
guys want to get some good energy into
you
and the the whole album will be out i
think august 6
we put the whole album out and uh and
then
we'll be hitting [ __ ] the red rocks
have you ever been to red rocks
i haven't been yeah we drove by it when
we were living in houses dude
over in colorado right right like
that that's a a legendary music venue
legendary you got to pop in there one
day y'all even i don't know but here you
wanna
even pop it on us you can pop in yeah
dude
don't do any special surprises for
anybody not not with the office
i i i i'll do some different [ __ ] man
i'll set myself on fire that's cool
right
that's kind of cool right now man that
can we let people know about like uh you
got social media we want to
get people on there anyway that's enough
i mean you can check me out i guess i
i'm not able to
i'll promote well i'll tell you that i
don't i don't promote well
but i am at what's uh right yeah i'm
having nothing
i'm gonna get on there man i i know what
i said can i ask your advice on
something real quick if we have time
yeah sure so steve uh he doesn't like me
talking about it but he had a rap
career for like i don't know like a
couple months right now we're
doing a redemption album and we want to
get this together we've talked to method
man we talked to logic we talked to all
these people that are like dude let me
drop a track on it we talk to t-pain
everybody
let's back it up right here wait wait
wait let me just ask you a question and
then you can
my question is if we were going to start
a redemption album
you guys didn't even know what we're
redeeming okay
back when i was on drugs i was out of
control
okay i i had this sorry to put you on
the spot
it's all good i had this hair brain idea
i said oh man wouldn't it be funny
if uh if i made a a rap a rap song
i made this rap song i called it it was
called
hard as a rock right which is kind of
funny it's like i'm a hard gangster guy
but i'm just like hard as a rock means
like i got a boner
and it was you know you know you don't
want to mess with me i'm hard as a rock
like you know like it was it was a funny
one-time thing i did it just for a laugh
it wasn't like there wasn't any money
i ended up going into this um pitch
meeting at comedy central and i was i
broke the ice in the meeting i was
pitching a tv show
but i broke the ice i said oh man check
out this this this rap song i made
and i'm playing hard as a rock and the
guy the executive for comedy central he
said at the end of the meeting
he said i'll tell you man i don't give a
[ __ ] about the tv show you just tried to
pitch me
but that rap song but that rap song was
hilarious man i did
i think you should make a comedy
gangster rap album
and so so that was how like it became a
thing
now i ended up with uh my lawyer at the
time was the the lawyer for uh
for for the notorious b.i.g estate that
vernon brown he did the cash money he's
all up in the middle yeah vernon brown
and
and uh i told vernon brown about this
and he said oh man [ __ ] comedy central
records he says
i'm going to get you on universal music
group
so yeah so i went and met with like
sylvia rohn and [ __ ] you know i [ __ ]
got
a legit bonafide record deal with the
universal music group to make
hard as a rock the album right
and uh and i was off to the races man i
started recording tracks
i recorded a track with be real i
recorded a track with
mop with cool g rap like it was like
kind of a who's who of this fight
but the thing was as i was doing it i
was also
spinning out of control like in a bad
way and
and what uh the music that i was making
wasn't particularly
dope because i was just not like you
know i wasn't okay
you know i wasn't working and it got to
a point where i was
so not okay with the drugs and alcohol
and i had to go
to rehab and get sober and everything
and the whole album project went away
and it really represents the most
embarrassing
like worst chapter of my life and i am
looking to redeem that
at this point so so scott just jumped up
and he's basically
like hey he was trying to rap i'm sorry
dude you know before i'm sorry i'm gonna
pass
mike back to you scott but let me say
one thing about so
you basically started losing control
basically going to the studio just to
party after a while right
i would record but it was it was dark
man it was it was good
it was dark i understand so i as an
artist that that
spent some time in that world i get you
and so now
you kind of focus you can see clear and
you're like yo should i go back and
redeem myself and
recreate that album yeah i think i mean
even if it was just a track even
but i think that in the headspace i'm at
now
like with i got focus i got hustle
and and i got clarity and uh
and i i don't know man i think uh i
think i could make something kind of
special
and and everyone that we've talked to
has been pretty into the idea
um so i don't know i'll probably
probably be in a studio
before too long so my question is what
was the question though he had a
question yeah my question is what do we
start with first do we get to produce or
do we get the beat do we get the lyrics
like how do how do we get it going from
start to finish i think you get
you get agreements first because music
is pretty
music is particularly crazy you get all
creative you go down the track
and then with no deals yeah and then
you can't clear [ __ ] and then you got it
like fighting
you know oh no i think you got to have
agreements before you can even
create right yeah i mean sadly yes but
that's that's that's when you're
looking to go grab everybody else to
participate with you
if you're looking now maybe let me stop
let me just do my little wizard thing
here
maybe it ain't about having all those
great artists and other artists part of
what you're doing
right maybe this is what you're doing
not what they're doing and they're not
invited to the party right and i say
that to say that if you think about
comedy albums
right dave chappelle
fred fox at one point the biggest
selling albums were comedy albums
right mr pryor was a gold artist before
he was a famous
movie star and all that right you're
already a famous guy
with with movies and and talks and pod
and and series all that [ __ ] right
how do you now think about okay
i do want to do my rap and whether
whether you make it serious or
make it comedy is up to you right right
but but
if you if you're saying that you're
making it on brand
you don't need a lot of [ __ ]
you do what you do
you know what i mean and just do it and
then when it's done
right you could be like okay this is
what i got then said you know what
it'll be funny if method man came on
here it'd be funny if
if logic came on here but you already
had
havoc that's another interesting i like
that
i like that well hey man i think uh dear
i can't thank you enough man like i said
my pleasure man
it's been very healing for me to to talk
to you that
man i'd love to talk to rayquan one day
man okay maybe maybe
i'm not asking you to to ask him
anything but if you could
reach out to the chef and just tell him
hey i talked to stevo
and he sent his best wishes and his
respect that that was
that would mean a lot to me and i could
do that dude thank you
thank you man and um dude like just
congratulations man
on on like you and me we're
like we're we're up there man and we
have not
we have not even [ __ ] peaked yet man
let's keep building
and i'll i'll see you further down the
road steve oh it's been a pleasure
brother
thank you thank you so much
yeah dude i told you man
an impressive episode of wild ride with
stevo
man there's so much crap going on right
now
like my days are ridiculous
i mean i'm going back out on tour
with new bits man oh i hope you guys get
to come see me on the bucket list tour
it's insane
and jackass forever like dude
it's all downhill from here so
thanks for sticking around man i love
you